studio and he's with Almera sure she
goes what's cool
Rex uh welcome
yeah and I
think for them for those who do not know
you yet yes I'm very nervous right now
Rex thank you for such a wonderful event
actually I was thinking what is on your
chest bucket list because well there are
so many events organized in Saint Louis
do you have another idea well eventually
when we have a St Louis and
participating I'd like to host a world
championship match here
and wouldn't it be great if the St Louis
was a female
and was in the world championship match
that would make Yasser happy too and
Judith Polgar what a wonderful interview
with her that we had it was very
interesting for all of us and then I
wanted to ask you that I think that this
year we have 10 events broadcasted so I
think more than 73 days of Chess wow
Saint Louis is well is it the chest
capital and not enough in the world so
how about the team event
let's say the United States against the
world I think that is a great idea and I
was just going over it with joy we've
got the people that'll do it we've got
the horses you know we got fobby and and
uh Hikaru and Lavon and Lanier
uh Wesley yeah we can do it bring them
on okay
well uh yes there's going to be the
captain of the United States team uh I
oh
I don't know anymore do you
um Rex we already have the winner and
Anna zato is the first American winner
congratulations on a very well done
Hannah so well I think that it makes you
very proud yes
so you have been followed the event for
I follow them very carefully but don't
ask me for any insightful comments
well today we have this absolute
and Anna the game
extremely complicated at the beginning
okay so it's a very complicated middle
game which is heading towards the end
game right now
who are you supporting
well I have to be officially neutral but
I but I think Irena here should jump and
get a kinger or am I mixing up my games
I'm sorry I mean there's actually a much
better here uh well since I got the
secret piece of information I know that
you're training with Yasser tell us a
little bit about this oh well he was
just trying to show off how patient he
could be with the student and he took me
on for an hour and it was it was amazing
it was it was great fun though because
we uh covered uh
a game that uh
I was just played recently and then he
covered one of my games from the
internet and I thought the whole world
would rise and Revolt looking at my
moves but Yasser didn't he was very
patient and steady he put up with it
well I have a question then for yes sir
Easter eggs a good student actually he's
marvelous because Rex is sitting under
the board and he's going wow that's
really good the the the game I showed uh
Rex was between Fabi and Magnus and it
was the first game that Fabi had won in
eight years in classical chess so I said
okay Rex this is the position I'm going
to show you and you have to here it
comes
correctly predict Bobby's moves you
don't just predict right correctly and I
was really shocked in fact
it was about 10 move combination he
found about eight of them eight out of
ten and I asked Rex directly I said Rex
did you see this game before and he said
no sir no sir so uh he surprised me and
by the way it was a tune-up it was just
making sure that he had all of his
tactics so he impressed and yeah
genuinely it wasn't a tune-up it was a
total remove total overhaul no I told
you I need a week for that Rex the
tune-up was for an hour that was good uh
Rex what is your favorite opening
as black I think so yeah as black if
it's against E4 Sicilian otherwise the
grunfeld and what type of the sicilium
uh the hyper-accelerated dragon so
grandfather and the dragon you were you
have a very aggressive style well I
didn't know that somebody told me that
you know I thought I was just being a
mild-mannered chess player but I said no
that's pretty aggressive so and in these
tournament uh well we have such a great
number of decisive games yeah well
compared to the Sinker food cup I wanted
to have your comments about this well
the women are probably better players
than the men
that's why we get more decisive games
I hope that gets back to the men
well thank you so much for thank you for
this interview and wonderful job you and
Yasser and Nazi the best team in the
world there's no question about it no
well we are probably the finest one
thank you thank you Rex we are
definitely enjoying ourselves thank you